let's play a little which doesn't belong
in hawaii on this friday edition of pft
live peter quarterbacks who got a vote
of confidence this week which doesn't
belong and why baker mayfield derek carr
kirk cousins
i would say
baker mayfield because he's the only one
of the three
that i think is going to play
the next 10 years with his team
wow wow
wow um
see i'm not so sure of that i'd say he's
the one of the three that still has yet
to prove he can get the kind of big
money contract that the other two have
gotten and i do think jared goff and
carson wentz are cautionary tales for
paying a guy after only three years i
think the browns should give it another
year before they they decide that baker
mayfield is the guy for the next 10
years because we're not that far removed
from a 2019 when he was not very good at
all but he definitely was improved and
very good in 2020. all right nfc north
franchise tag candidates which doesn't
belong and why bears receiver alan
robinson lions receiver kenny galladay
packers running back aaron jones
man that is a really really good one i'm
just going to uh
i'm going to throw a dart here and i'm
going to say kenny galladay
uh because i think there's a better
chance that the other two guys get
franchised
uh than gallaudet even though i think
gallaudet is a long-term
uh
you know if you've got two or three guys
on the absolute top level of receivers
gallaudet is on that secondary level
with i think he's going to be great for
a long time
i'm going to say aaron jones just
because i think it would be a mistake
for the packers to invest and we had the
estimate earlier this week of 11.1
million which seems high with the cap
going down but eight figures for one
year with a running back
i wouldn't do it there's too many other
running backs out there as we discussed
earlier in the program every round of
the draft or undrafted that's a lot of
money to plunk down and it basically
makes it one more year with the guy
because then he's got the leverage for
the second year with a 20 raise over
what he gets this year and then he
becomes a free agent in 2022 afc north
free agent pass rushers which doesn't
belong in why
ravens pass rusher matthew judon carl
lawson the bengals duprey of the
steelers
well the only guy of those three who i
think is probably gone from his team is
bud dupree
my guess is that the other two guys are
going to get signed either for one year
or
long term
um thing about bud dupree that's very
interesting at least in my mind is that
he's playing his best football in the
first half of last season and then gets
hurt and he's out for the year
who is going to have the faith
in a year of the declining cap
to make him a
name it a 15 million dollar a year
player that's going to be the big
challenge to create that kind of market
for bud dupree
shireen williams made a great point on
pft pm earlier this week he may end up
with the steelers on a one-year deal
just because no one is going to take
that leap of faith he'll look around if
the money's not out there stay in
pittsburgh another year and then try to
get paid again next year that's the
great tragedy the franchise tag you
don't get the generational wealth you
get good money for one year you suffer a
serious injury you never get the
contract that you would have gotten if
you had been a free agent i'm going to
say judon because i don't think the
ravens are going to tag him i don't
think they're going to sign him i think
they're just going to find another way
too much money to tag him because they
tagged him last year he gets a 20 bump
veterans cut this week which doesn't
belong and why kyle van noy of the
dolphins kyle rudolph of the vikings
jared cook technically cut option not
picked up tight end of the saints which
doesn't belong and why
kyle van noy uh
cut by the dolphins really really
surprised me and the reason he gets cut
is that they got this van ginkel guy who
came out of nowhere last year and played
very well he made huge plays for that
defense all year long so they could
afford to let van noy go but
this sort of continues a trend with that
organization and it's been a lot of guys
on the offensive coaching staff
but
they've admitted mistakes on a lot of
guys in brian flurry's first two years
pl two years plus
and and so to me
i think you've got to start looking at
this like okay let's be a little bit
more cautious on who we're giving the
guaranteed money to
right out of the box
i'd say cook doesn't belong because he's
clearly the best of the three now he's
streaky and at times he disappears but
he's capable of being dominant and i
think he's a guy the saints would have
kept but for this incredible cap problem
that they have this year and they are
slashing everywhere they can to try to
get on the right side of the spending
limit which is expected to be 182 to 183
million
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports